well shadow health centrally we're
streeting is with us now i can't even
begin to imagine how these parents must
be and there was a culture of telling
them that there was nothing that could
have been done and they had to go home
and potentially try to get pregnant
again when are we going to stop this
well i really hope that today's report
marks a turning point and
delivers some justice for families who
had to campaign to get the ocondom
review in the first place which i think
they should never have been put in that
position when we've been talking to
donna ockendon and her team we're not
expecting
donna to pull her punches with today's
report so
as you say kate i can't imagine what
these mothers have gone through but i
hope that at the end of
this journey of campaigning for justice
that they feel a sense of vindication
and also assurance that this isn't going
to happen to women in the future because
i think
on top of everything else they've
experienced the only real comfort we can
provide to these families now is to say
that the truth has come out
lessons will genuinely be learned and
there'll be a turning point so what
guidance is she giving you
uh what i haven't seen the
recommendations in fact i think she's
going to be setting these things out as
must do's not recommendations i think
she's going to be insisting that the
politicians right across the political
divide act as my expectation the health
secretary will accept um the findings in
full and we will hold him to it but i
hope this will be a moment of consensus
in the house of commons they've got
plenty of other arguments going on on
health today but i hope there will be
some consensus on this the thing that
does worry me about maternity in
particular as we know that there's a
shortage of nhs staff right across the
board but it's particularly acute in
maternity services and even last year we
had hundreds of cases where women were
turned away from maternity units because
there weren't staff there to receive
them so
this report does look at historic
failures dating back 20 years and across
successive governments and i want to
acknowledge that as a as a labour
politician this is not just about the
current governments the successive
governments but there are real
challenges today too and i think we've
got to face up to those so that every
expectant mother in this country can
have the confidence and certainty of
knowing that when she gives birth she'll
be in safe hands as you point out you
know historically the labour government
was not without guilt and we saw what
happened with the mid-staffordshire
scandal and it all comes down to the
fact that um
parents and and patients are
complaining and politicians are not
listening to them do you accept that
politicians in the past have not always
listened to people when they've had
heartfelt concerns
yeah and it's not just politicians i
think the nhs has to learn lessons as
well
some of the testimony we've been hearing
from
um from from grieving mums this morning
about their experiences of asking
questions raising concerns asking for
cesarean sections being denied i think
there's a lesson here about listening to
patients
you know of course we when we put our
hands ourselves in the hands of
clinicians we respect their clinical
expertise and their judgment but we also
know our own bodies and i think
sometimes the nhs isn't always good at
listening to patients in the way that
needs to happen so i think there's a
cultural change that's needed as well as
the investment in the staff the
equipment the technology that the nhs
needs and to provide high quality
and and accessible services not just on
maternity but right across the board
where there are real challenges in the
nhs right now and given that you've
spoken to the reports author how
confident are you that what happened in
shrewsbury would never happen again
well if we listen and if we act i think
we will be as confident as we can be and
i think that's the responsibility on the
government today it will be a
cross-party uh responsibility as well um
and i can i can commit to those
recommendations those must do's uh as
i'm sure sajid javid the health
secretary will will be holding into
account as the opposition but we'll also
be taking it on board in terms of our
own plans uh you know for the next
general election where we hope labour
will be in government will you from
friday will you be testing if you've got
um covert symptoms yeah i think people
should and to be honest so they can't
afford to well that's the that's the big
question isn't it kay i think what's
what's effectively happening now is is a
stealth tax it's a covered tax on people
doing the right things i'm glad that
finally the government's seen sense and
said that nhs staff will get access to
free testing
but but but what about what about
families that will struggle to pay for
the test what about those people that
are going regularly into care homes to
see their parents or grandparents and
will want to do the right thing before
going in you know we've got rising bills
we know the cost of living is a big
issue and we've got big tax rise coming
in april 2 which will hit families so on
top of this to add an additional cost
whilst lecturing the public on personal
responsibility when it comes to covert
which is in itself is laughable given
the actions of the prime minister we've
got to make sure that people can afford
to do the right thing and that's why i
think it's the wrong decision at the
wrong time to take away access to free
testing now i've been reading my notes
have you because i was going to go on to
ask you about what happened uh with as
far as partier is concerned we've had
the first tranche of fines 20 separate
fines don't know how many people but 20
separate fines have been issued people
were breaking the law at the heart of
downing street when uh the rest of the
country were in lockdown what does that
say about the culture of downing street
well it says the prime minister's a liar
because he told the house of commons
repeatedly that there were no parties
and no wrongdoing no law breaking no
rule breaking numbers he did he says
that he wasn't aware well he was there i
mean that's that's what i think is so
completely untenable about boris
johnson's position as prime minister now
uh you know i can't think of a single
prime minister that has walked into the
house of commons and deliberately lied
there may be times when prime ministers
have been wrong there may be times where
prime ministers might bend the truth or
stretch the truth and and every week of
prime minister's questions successive
prime ministers um have been guilty of
answering different questions to one
that's asked these are the these are the
tricks of the politicians trade because
sometimes the truth can be uncomfortable
when presented with difficult questions
you've seen that but to have a prime
minister lie to the country to the house
of commons to the queen and still be
imposed is completely unacceptable what
should happen to rishi sunak if he
receives a fixed penalty notice well i
think i think it's the same rule applies
to everyone his position would also be
untenable and it's amazing how invisible
the chancellor has been over the
partygate allegations he lives next door
um i think he should be really upfront
now himself about whether or not he's
been involved in any wrongdoing and
upfront with the country
and i hope that
in the case of all government ministers
we will be able to return to a position
where we can take them
at their word when they categorically
tell us something is not true we can
believe them but how can we when we've
got a prime minister at the top who has
knowingly lied where conservative mps
are tolerating this and i think we've
got to a point now where i suspect boris
johnson will lead the conservative party
into the next election because tory mps
have made themselves complicit in his
lying and ultimately it's now up to the
voters to ask themselves a question are
you the public
comfortable
and tolerant of a situation where the
prime minister can knowingly tell
bareface lies to you the british people
and if you're not happy with this you've
got an opportunity in may at the local
elections to send boris johnson packing
and you'll have an opportunity at the
next general election send the prime
minister packing to final thought just
before i let you go right on the front
page of yesterday's telegraph that men
who go for scans in hospital are now
going to be asked whether they are
pregnant is that appropriate use of nhs
funds i don't know about funds i do
think we need a bit of common sense
tolerance and reason in this debate
about
trans people and gender identity and i i
think particularly in terms of clinical
settings the nhs has tried and tested
guidelines on how to deal with people
respectfully um you know when i went in
for my kidney scans last year i did not
need to be asked whether i was pregnant
evidently not if someone is going in who
has undergone gender reassignment or is
going through the process of
transitioning maybe presents in a
different gender to the sex they were
born into then maybe those questions are
appropriate but we've got to take things
on a case-by-case basis apply some
common sense and in terms of the more
general debate about trans rights and
inclusion the the tension that exists
between sex-based rights and gender
identity which we're seeing playing out
on our television screens on programs
like yours let's just have a bit more um
calm common sense
decency and respect in this debate uh uh
and and i i i must say as just speaking
for myself i've kind of been pulling my
hair out some of the gotcha questions on
um tv programs and radio programs
recently and the extent to which
we're kind of tying ourselves up in
knots on the wrong sorts of issues on
this we we have a small but significant
number of people in this country who do
not feel that they are
in in the right gender they're born into
the wrong sex and and i can't imagine
what that's like i know from talking to
people it's unbearably difficult and
we've got to treat those people with
respect there are also lots of women who
when it comes to single sex spaces are
worried and afraid and and there are
cases sometimes where they've got good
reason to be afraid and they've been
some horrific cases we've seen in the
media recently whether in the nhs or in
prisons so we've got to acknowledge that
and address it not try and silence it or
stifle it but find a way through
and a compromise through in the way that
we have done before on sexual
orientation for example equal marriage
we got to a compromise that maybe not
everyone loved but everyone could live
with and we did that by listening
reasonable respectful debate and finding
a way through and i think that's the
answer on on trans rights we're out of
time um how's your health now you're
better 100 recovered i'm very very
pleased to say i'm very relieved too
pleased to see you as well thrilled to
see you thank you
for joining us much appreciated